what the is wrong with trailers
these days my guys not only did we get a
new ant-man trailer but we also got a
new trailer for Terminator Genisys and
in the last trailer I was like I have a
theory it looks like Arnold is the
Terminator from Terminator 2 but he went
back in time further to protect Sarah
Connor because the t1000 was sent back
there you know this whole time theory
thing words I owe the timeline is now
completely different this trailer
doesn't want to confirm that no those
would be spoilers okay be honest with
you this is a spoiler alert for the
movie because I'm gonna talk about the
trailer that should never happen
should never have to give a spoiler
alert because I'm talking about a
trailer trailer should not have spoilers
as far as I can tell I watch this
trailer and I was like no people should
not know that going into the movie so
you've been warned I guess if you've
managed to stay clear of it in this
world of social networking this
interwoven web of spoilers called
Facebook and Twitter because I know how
it goes Sunday night if I haven't
watched The Walking Dead or Game of
Thrones I stayed off off line yes
you have to do that for terminator
trailers to this trailer shows us more
of what we already knew from the last
trailer you know Sarah Connors been
hanging out with Arnold the Terminator
for over a decade you know there's
hanging out the who drop my baby buggy
bumpers and Kyle Reese goes begs like
what how did you know all about this
this is crazy and then this is it
you see John Connor and he's like hey
mom
he's like John I completely recognize
you for some odd reason but Arnold just
starts wasting just boo-boos or shooting
them John Connor has become a hybrid of
men and machines not a man he's not a
machine just like a super nanotechnology
cyborg of some kind is you know it shows
his entire physical structure like
blowing away likes and so then Ana but I
don't know what he is one is it's not
like a terminator mimicking John Connor
apparently John Connor is a terminator
and was sent back in time now this is
weird on a couple of the one they made
John Connor a terminator ballsy but I'm
open to that they surprised some
people because like Hale Terminator 2 is
just one of the grace of all time but
you're dealing with new timelines and
people are gonna start shuffling
around heroes become villains villains
become heroes that's what I mean Sagat
and Street Fighter is kind of good now
right when franchises go on for decades
things shift like that I'm open to the
possibility of this happening I will go
into that with an open mind
technicality they are being I have to
not know about it until I'm in the movie
theater because that seems pretty huge
some about these Terminator movies just
spoil things for people remember T to
that standoff in the hallway Arnold ray
gun t1000 raises his gun john connor's
in the middle you don't know a t-1000
t1000 you think he's just a regular dude
you're like oh shoot oh she's a
terminator before he shoots John Connor
and Arnold goes good down-home and John
gets down he blows his thing away he
starts protecting John Connor and when I
saw that I was like if you didn't know
that that would be mind blowing but the
movie was marketed as Arnold being a
good guy because I guess they felt they
had to do that but it was like back in
the early 90s then you fast forward to
Terminator Salvation I wasn't crazy
about the movie personally but it shows
in the trailer there's a spoiler alert
for Terminator Salvation it shows in the
trailer Marcus writes of Terminator and
when I was watching the movie I was like
they'd be a lot cooler if that was a
reveal that you didn't know it'd be like
mind blowing like oh my god add an
element of cool to the movie now we have
Terminator Genisys and again they're
showing us that John Connor is a
terminator it's just showing way too
much in this movie so much it irritated
me my friend and I were watching it
while the trailers going on my friends
like too much way too much and it was
like well I'm glad I saw the amazing
spider-man trailer again but how amazing
spider-man was by the end of the Amazing
Spiderman trailer you're like I just saw
the movie that's how I felt in this one
you're like I just saw the movie you
want to show that there's another
Terminator in the movie fine it shows
him getting out of the fire maybe you
can show them forming and then cut it
off to people like ooh who is it brannad
they'll probably piece it together in
the movie when they see John Connor
randomly show up in the past the point
is though why is that in the trailer it
did nothing but irritate me nothing but
infuriate me the fact that I saw that I
was like that's a pretty major spoiler
it's possible I will watch the movie and
bigger shit's happening where I'm like I
know that you think it's a spoiler but
it's actually one of the smaller things
in the movie but I really doubt it
they're just gonna do nothing but piss
people off they're gonna be three kinds
of people in the world folks people who
are pissed at John Connors a terminator
people are okay with that but they're
pissed that they showed that in the
trailer and people who were fine with
both may just want to watch the movie
because the small margin of people in
that one and if for nothing else it
looks like this movie is throwing way
too much at us you know I mean Kyle
Reese goes into the past he was working
with Sarah Connor they got to take out
the t1000 but things are different
they're different enough to where I
could watch the movie and go you're
gonna have different events familiar
characters but different events know be
enough for me I go okay cool and now you
have what the t1000 a new timeline and
this new John Connor terminators the
t1000 get wiped out in the beginning of
the movie by t1 Arnold gets wiped out in
this trailer in this movie also I don't
know guys just real
weird to me I just walked away from this
trailer going that was dumb I was
intrigued enough to watch this movie but
now the trailer just made me irritated
because I feel like I already watched
the movie so that's my question you guys
the terminator genisys trailer have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more